i mean the show is [ __ ] phenomenal
the pitch was amazing i wanted so badly
to play this sheriff and
we were gonna he was like you're gonna
have three weeks you're gonna rap bly
you're gonna have three weeks prep
so he tells me this in november he's
like yeah you're gonna have three weeks
prep we go straight into midnight mass
so i was talking to my team and i was
like well
i'll be done by june
and
like it's basically like almost one show
i went from a blind manner to midnight
mass without a break i can keep the same
apartment it's kind of like you know
it's it's easy this is yeah i'm staying
um so and the only thing mike told me in
november was was
uh
put on weight because i was too slim and
i was slimming blind man and we wanted
to look a bit bigger in age and bit
daddy
so the weather and he's been there yeah
with life he's dealing with his son's
[ __ ] yeah
and like we figured i figured like uh
you know
a you know weight makes you look older
and and
there's no gym on the island maybe
you're a doughy sheriff now that used to
be a you know fit nypd cop so basically
it was fat jason mamoa i remember the
first conversation we had was like long
hair
i had the scar
beard we were going for an earthy look
so from you do look older in it yeah i
mean a lot older it's crazy yeah because
you have some grays yeah they put them
in some grass
but what happened was
i put on 30 pounds for
for mass or fat wow so literally
midnight mass midnight mass oh yeah and
i did it the bad way because again this
isn't marvel oh like i was eating
mcflurries
i was eating doughnuts i'm not healthy
no so i i got really bad health issues
so what happened was i get fat in blind
manner you can half see it if you start
watching the back end i'm like the
apron's like
it's [ __ ] tight
and i'm doing what i'm doing so i've got
three weeks man
three weeks to get this this guy up on
its feet and we
we get it up on its feet i'm now 30
pounds heavier
and then we have a table read of all
[ __ ] seven episodes
of midnight all seven yeah in one day
never done that that's exhausting yeah
oh my god
that's like that's like seven hours
check the date march 11th
2020.
so we hear rumors about this covert
thing's [ __ ] weird isn't it it's it's
a bit more serious than we thought
we've all flown in from different places
we're sitting in this tiny room in an
office 17 of us or whatever just like
all right are we doing the next scene
and like that's the room and we're like
this is [ __ ] weird uh
and on the
the day after i got a call from trevor
mace who's our producer and he was like
go home we're taking a two week break
because of this covered lockdown
we're all on flights within an hour or
two back to la and then we didn't shoot
mass until august july
and in that time
so what turned into two weeks turned
into like five months but now you have
to keep on that way
that's exactly what happened and i was
waking up in the middle of night
vomiting stomach acid
swear to god it was like reflux or
whatever yeah i'd like because i was
still trying to keep it on and i
couldn't it wasn't my frame i remember
i'd go to sleep and just be like and
they would be like down me it'd be in
the beds and like
i spoke to mike and i was like i can't
do this
and i remember had a conversation with
kate and and also my best friend who was
a consultant on midnight master who's
our islamic consultant
and
being brown and like she's like you're
kate's kate's been amazing for me but
she she was like you're a leading man
why are you making it hard for them to
see that she was like be the best
version of yourself on camera
make the sheriff hot lose the weight get
do whatever